[Music]
uh do you have high expectations for
Sunday how how do you feel how are you
preparing for it I have high
expectations in terms of I'm planning to
have a good time and try to enjoy
everything so it doesn't happen too so
it's not too quick um I have high
expectations for the HT
Locker um I'm just looking forward to it
being in the middle of everything and
I'm I'm totally uh Chu that our little
film can even get that
far you you alluded to it when you
accepted the award but um with with one
eye on Sunday how good an actress is
car
um
I think it's it's really important to
not compare her with other actresses all
the time because what she can do is
something that only she can do and that
is her easy access to emotion her Strong
high high work ethic beautiful voice
musicality
boys uh interpretation uh skills she's a
she's a brilliant actress she is
um I think she
will stay where she is for a long long
time particularly because she hand
things she handles her Talent really
well and she's very down to
earth is she this
year I it's such an it's such
an abstract thing to talk
about
um but and you can't say I I don't know
how how at what level Mar Street was at
when she was car's age um so no I can't
compare them at
all but she's
good she's very
good you know it says on the on on the
title UK and France so how much is this
movie French well it's two shooting days
in Paris um a very small Dogma likee
little Montage uh my birthday was one of
them so uh it is a it is a totally
British film but what I did forget to
mention um when I was that uh confused
in there was that endgame
entertainment uh has uh financed the
film with BBC and that's an LA based
company so um financially it is very
much an American Film
actually but in its well the nationality
is UK I don't know about France but
maybe that's why I'm wearing the
you mention it that um you were
competing another foreign films than
there are foreign language and we
consider British films like American
films like a more domestic films yes so
how you feel well I think it's a it's I
am Danish so it's fantastic to have
directed a film that can be part of this
foreign film group and still have a film
that is nominated for Oscar on Sunday I
think this this film is European in its
uh Soul um it comes out of an
independenta tradition it uh uh I my
background is extremely independent as
I'm a Dogma director uh but uh so we're
just very very lucky that it is all that
it also qualifies for the Academy Awards
but it is a European F not that the
British consider themselves Europeans
they speak of Europe as some
other yeah how's car been dealing with
all the and all the success after how
she
sheing I think Carrie enjoys things more
and more
because whilst all of this attention has
been taking place she's also shot three
or four maybe even five films since we
shot an education and and
she I mean I'm sure she loves all this
attention but she also loves her work
and she she gets a good balance and U
like I guess all of us working is is the
absolute best thing but this is not bad
[Music]
either
he